what up space fan goes in here from
anime uproar and today we are going to
be talking about how strong the main
antagonist and strongest demon in demon
slayer is we're going to be dissecting
the demon king of pop moves on himself
if you like seeing demon slayer videos
on this channel and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video with a friend if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell because if
you don't you will miss future demon
slayer videos you can also follow anime
up for audio on spotify itunes or
wherever else you listen to podcasts if
you want to get early access to all of
our content including our weekly demon
slayer chapter reviews i also want to
give a big thank you to our patrons who
helped make videos like this one
possible more on those amazing people
later keep in mind there will be manga
spoilers in this video we are going to
be looking at all the relevant evidence
in order to determine exactly how strong
Mouzon is you've been warned now without
further ado let's jump into it moves on
became the first theme in over 1,000
years ago and he's been able to turn
humans into demons ever since he usually
looks physically about 30 years old
however he has recently been affected by
an aging poison that's added over 9,000
years to his 1000 years making him over
10,000 years old in another sense so
yeah a drink is a tricky business when
it comes to this guy moves on appears to
be related to the leading family of the
demon hunters - oh boy ishiki family the
former leader revealed that the monster
moves on came out of this family and led
the family to be cursed every child now
born in their family as weak and dies
early a priest told them that a demon
came from their bloodline so they must
dedicate their souls to defeating him
and if they do that their family will
not die out since then no one in their
family lived beyond 30 and they've been
dedicated to stopping Meuse off we are
told that it was a generous doctor in
the late 700 s who turned Mouzon into a
demon Muhsin was sick and he was
supposed to die before he turned 20
who's on suffered so much and took
medicine just to live a little longer
but when he was told that he would die
because his disease was worsening he got
angry and killed the doctor then he
found out that the doctors medicine was
actually working this medicine saved him
but also turned him into a demon a demon
who has much in common with the figure
of the vampire he obtained a strong body
but he could no longer be in the Sun the
Sun was deadly to him
he craved human flesh and began eating
people in order to keep his seemingly
immortal life going he hated the fact
that he couldn't go out in the Sun
though he wanted a body that could
survive the sunlight the doctor had used
a medicine known as blue spider lily but
Muslim had no idea where he could find
it he wished that he didn't kill the
doctor who had not yet perfected the
medicine he had given to Musa Musa I
messed up by killing a doctor and he was
frustrated because he traveled all over
Japan and couldn't find any blue spider
lilies his goal has always been the
attainment of the perfect immortal body
so he needed to find a way to withstand
the Sun he created a lot of demons in
the hopes that one would conquer the Sun
and eventually Mitsuko did in theory if
Musa now consumes nez eco he can become
immune to the Sun and become in his view
a perfect unkillable being before we get
into what that would mean exactly let's
look at some of Mullins most important
fights to get a sense of his power
currently around 400 years before the
main story when Mulan might have been
around 600 he encountered yuuichi
Tuvok Unni the breath of the Sun user yo
Deecee is the strongest demon ser in the
entire series and he used the original
and strongest breath style before this
encounter Mulan was wrecking everyone as
you'd expect the strongest demon to he
had brainwashed demon underlings like
Tamayo to help him out too when he first
saw you ichi he looked as confident as
ever he had no idea what was in store
for him
yuuichi admitted that his fight against
Mouzon was his most difficult one
he said that Mouzon possessed fearsome
speed in a long reach he says that even
a single scratch would kill him
likely because it would allow moves on
self destroying blood to enter his body
and spread for the first time ever
you're Ichi who was usually bored with
battle felt
chill down his spine so you're a teach
she did make sure to let us know that
Mouzon was strong but your et was still
stronger he cut moves on in two moves on
surprise the demon did not regenerate as
usual yo D cheese bright red blade which
represented the power of the Sun was
super effective against the strongest
demon so you're a teach he was clearly
going to win but then Mullins body burst
into 1,800 pieces of flesh
Beth flew in all directions with
incredible force you're Ichi amazingly
managed to cut a little more than 1500
of them but the other pieces escaped and
recombined together the pieces were the
size of a human head and Mulan was able
to regenerate from that mousse I made
sure to never show himself again in
front of you Ichi yo Deecee scared moves
on psychologically with his insane level
of skill but he still couldn't finish
moves on off in his lifetime so yet Ichi
was definitely stronger than moves on
but moves on easily appears to be the
second strongest character in the series
the only reason that the demon Slayers
including tangina were not finished off
sooner by moves on is because of
tomorrow's action no booze aging poison
that's been significantly slowing down
Musa moves on in theory could have
gotten stronger in the 400 years since
your reach is defeat but right now
because of the aging potion
he's definitely weaker and slower than
he was back then when he fought you Ichi
still though even in a weakened state he
gave what appeared to be very serious
injuries to the pillars he created upper
moons that the strongest demon slayers
had to work together in order to barely
defeat in chapter 194 tundra and agudo
are struggling to keep up in al two two
one fight they're doing their best to
stall moves on until dawn because their
only hope of killing him is the Sun so
Mulan is the second strongest character
in the series and he created a lot of
other demons that would make it in a top
10 strongest Demon Slayer characters
list like cocoa Zeebo
dolma and akiza however he is currently
getting weaker and weaker because of the
aging potion that's what we know so far
but we can now turn to the very
interesting territory of speculation
moves on recently mentioned the idea of
adapting to the aging potion I don't
think him man
this was a fluke it was probably
mentioned because it is likely to happen
Mouzon will adapt to the poison when
that happens he will resort back to his
strongest self likely an even stronger
version of himself than the one that
fought you Ichi
since he's gained experience and
absorbed many victims since then this
version of him should be able to finish
off any living character one on one no
problem tundra will have to up his game
and he'll probably need help from Mexico
and others too he'll need to somehow get
stronger and use others to fill the gap
between his skill and your e cheese
before he can ever hope to beat Musa
however let's say that mouton absorbed
mezu ko which is an extremely unlikely
event in my view but let's say he did
then he could potentially become immune
to the Sun what does this mean while
theoretically that would make him the
strongest character ever in demon slayer
that would arguably even put him above
your ichi think about it why was he so
affected by your e cheese bright red
blade and his breath of the Sun attacks
it is because you each he uses the power
of the Sun to fight if mu Sun was no
longer affected by the Sun then the
breath of the Sun would not be effective
against him he would have no trouble
quickly reconnecting his body parts no
matter how many times you cut him he
would regenerate and eventually chances
are he would get a hit on his opponent
and thus poison them with his cell
destroying blood if this happens Musa
would be virtually invincible so the
demon Slayers have to really hope that
this doesn't happen and if it does we'll
need to see Tundra unlock a new power
that we have yet to see in the series
moves on is one nesco away from being
potentially unstoppable I obviously hope
this doesn't happen because I along with
the rest of the fandom love nezu KO but
if somehow it did happen that would be
absolutely crazy in order to defeat
moose on Tundra would have to even
surpass you at E cheap it would
definitely make for an epic and
emotional final battle we'll have to
wait and see what happens
but that's how strong Mouzon is and how
strong he could potentially become and
that is it for today's video thank you
so much for watching let me know if you
think moose on is going to become immune
to the Sun before this series is all
or if he'll be stopped before that
happens
will the mangaka actually let him get to
full power if you enjoyed these demas
their videos they want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video with a friend if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or else you
will miss future demons their videos
remember that you can listen to these
demons their videos and reviews before
they're uploaded on YouTube if you
follow anime up or audio on Spotify
iTunes or wherever else you listen to
podcasts a special thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help us
survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost I want to thank our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Steven grata alo long autumn the
world stealers the school bus
Theisen Kirino a quiet respect and paid
hefa and I can't forget our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress fitted ala beat Anatole Cassatt
Suki alpha do angel Cruz team Sparky 65
cricket XP Rohan Kapoor Jessica Maloney
Emperor Taku Timothy Edward Vargas
Jeanne d'Arc Joel Stanton JCCC waka very
Gucci and Jessica Calif on thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon comm
anime out drawer and becoming a patron
today for as little as one dollar if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com/lenguin
you can also now join the youtube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer which ever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]
you